my name is Janine and I run blessings in
the backpack here in Bonneville Alberta
Canada I've been running this is the end
of our third year and I brought this
program to Bonneville because there was
a need in our community for children who
don't get enough to eat on weekend
[Music]
in 2008 I decided that I didn't want to
spend like that we had been spending and
there was more to life than just wait
until the paycheck ran out so I went to
library and picked up Dave Ramsey's
Total Money Makeover and it was a
wake-up call and how you could live a
different way and live more purposefully
[Music]
I've been married to my husband Kevin
for almost 15 years and we have one
daughter named Sophia who happens to be
on the ASD spectrum she is an amazing
kid who loves art and we love to spend
our summers at Lac des Zil in
Saskatchewan I did FPU in 2012 and I it
just reiterated the whole purpose of
living fully and what that looks like
exactly it doesn't look like driving a
BMW for me it means family time and
laughing your butt off to your gut hurts
and giving a lot of giving a giving is
probably the biggest thing when you no
longer owe anybody all of a sudden you
have all this money and you can do
whatever you want with it
and it has changed our lives and we are
living like no one else because of it
so we did whatever we wanted there was a
charity that you know we stayed behind
we we threw money at it a local church
in town had just started a food pantry
so I wrote him a check for $1000 so they
could buy a fridge I love to walk in off
the street
and write a check for $2,500 to a local
food bank we bought a milk fridge for
the milk program at her school for over
3 grand
we bought guitars for the school at
$2,000 it's just the best feeling in the
world to give give of yourself when you
start to think of yourself as more than
just a spectator in life you can do
whatever in it it's such a joyful
feeling after my daughter was diagnosed
with that with autism you feel you kind
of fall into a really black place and
you think that life is never gonna be
better than it is right now you stop
hoping that things are gonna be this way
for your child when they grow up and it
can be really lonely when you are
raising a special-needs child because
other outside people don't understand
your kid at all and you feel like you
have to explain everything to them while
I was feeling like that I think God gave
me something else to hold on to and I
think when you feel like you're sinking
if you can give to somebody or start a
new a program or something that you can
it helps lift you up when you start
helping others and you stop focusing so
much on yourself it makes you see a
bigger picture that no this life is what
you make it when I was working in the
schools and I would see kids come in
to eat breakfast I started wanting to
somehow branch out and do something with
that to help these kids on the weekend
because I was so thankful to my
daughter's elementary school for being
so wonderful with her and I wanted to
give back to kids the way that my
daughter had been given to you and
that's how I came at starting blessings
in a backpack
in order to bring blessings in a
backpack to Bonneville we had to
guarantee that we can fund three full
years at five thousand dollars a year
for a total of fifteen thousand dollars
they don't want people coming in
starting it for two months and running
out of money and then those kids relying
on that food already and not getting it
anymore
we wouldn't have been able to do that
when we had debt like $100 just given to
a kid coming to sell boyscout tins of
popcorn wasn't even wasn't even gonna be
feasible now that we became debt-free it
opened up this whole new world of giving
and it's um it's changed absolutely
everything in our lives I get to pack
food for kids I don't even know but I
feel really great knowing that there's
twenty four kids that are being fed this
weekend for a program we got to bring
here it brings us so much joy and and
just gratitude that we are able to bless
others to carry on and be their best
selves and and live a full life anyone
that's ever doubted themselves and then
push through it anyway
will get what that feels like when you
say thank you god I didn't listen to my
inner self and I just went past the fear
and just jumped because had I not done
that um we'd have more kids right now
that are struggling
[Music]
I get to see these kids on Thursdays
after school and they don't know who I
am but they're carrying their bags of
food that I had just packed for them and
they're so excited for anyone that has
enough to eat is probably nothing but
for kids that don't know what they're
gonna eat they know when they go home
they have something the day of a food
bag drop which happens to be a Thursday
morning every Thursday I do not know who
any of the children are I do not know
their families it could be a neighbor
for all I know and that's what the
beauty of blessings in a backpack is is
that nobody knows who it is they are
distributed by the staff so it's
completely confidential the secretaries
will when kids are out for recess they
will go put the bags inside of their
existing backpacks so that even other
children don't even know but you get the
occasional kid that's really excited
about what their food bags are and what
they get to eat so they swing them
around for the whole public to know they
don't even care they're just so happy
you have to have a start and an end
point but the end point is really just
the beginning you're gonna accomplish
some amazing things that you didn't even
think was gonna be possible because you
were so weighed down by your debt the
air smells different clothing feels
different your outlook on life you're
more positive you attract more positive
things in your life when you no longer
Ont buddy I want I want people to know
how this feels and you can do this
everyone can do this it doesn't matter
what you make you do not have to make
200 thousand dollars a year to be
debt-free it just starts with a plan
that's it
just a plan say yes to changing your
life say yes to being different than
everybody else say yes to driving an
older car than your friends do say yes
to living in a 40 year old health like
we do just say yes to all of it and it
all changes and then you stop caring
what other people are doing because mate
while that's fine for them you've got
bigger plans that you want to see
succeed and I'm just so glad that we
jumped in we got debt-free our whole
life is just completely changed we are
living like no one else so that my
daughter can go to any kind of school
she wants to because we have the funding
for it in cash
if you can dream it up you can make it
happen
but when you have debt it takes choices
away if you have that you can't make the
choices that you really really want in
your heart and when you live debt-free
it opens up a whole new can of worms for
you so you better be ready for the ride
because it's brilliant
I mean this it's friggin awesome I love
it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]